The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open CourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT Open CourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today we talk
about ridership forecasting.
Last time we talked
about cost modeling.
So we were looking
at models to estimate
costs of [INAUDIBLE] changes.
Today we look at how
ridership responds,
which is the other big question
the agencies, [INAUDIBLE]
agencies have when a
network will suffer changes.
So we'll talk about route
ridership prediction
needs and issues,
alternative approaches
to ridership prediction
and forecasting.
We'll look at some examples
from several agencies,
notably the Toronto Transit
commission and [INAUDIBLE]..
We'll look at more advanced
sort of DIS based models,
simultaneous equations
models, and show
some examples of
software packages
that people use for this.
So one note before we see
is that all of this lecture
focuses on short run root
level prediction methods.
We're not talking about
regional level effects of, say,
the land use influence on
ridership, or the total amount.
We're talking about
specifically transit ridership.
And it's a little
more short run.
So you'll see how that plays
a role as we move forward.
OK, so what are the roles?
Why do we need ridership models?
Of course, predicting ridership
is tied to predicting revenue,
right?
So when there is any change
an agency is interested in,
will they lose ridership
or gain ridership,
and what impact will that
have on their fair bidding?
So first role is predicting
ridership revenues
or total fare changes.
This is the most
typical example.
All agencies go through
periodic fare changes
unless they are completely free.
So usually you want
system-wide predictions.
And the approaches are
fairly specific calculations.
So you might estimate
some risk elasticity
of the response, average
response of ridership
to fare changes.
You could use a time
theory [INAUDIBLE] model.
That's a better approach
if you want to control
for external factors.
And the best methods use a
two-stage market segment model,
recognizing that different
segments of the population
might have different
elasticities,
different responses
to a fair change.
The second role is predicting
ridership and revenue
for general agency planning
and budget [INAUDIBLE],,
so not necessarily fair changes.
Here, again, we need a
system-wide prediction.
And the key elements are
trend projection and another--
this is another place where
a time series [INAUDIBLE]
model plays a role.
Here we're not
necessarily looking
at a response to
something, not anything
that the agency has
control over, for example.
But you might have the
impacts of gas prices
or other external factors,
population growth,
things like that, so trends,
seasonality, things like that.
Then there's predicting
ridership revenue
as a result of service changes.
This is the other
very typical example.
So here we are interested
in more detailed root level
prediction as opposed to
system wide prediction.
And therefore, we need
to take into account
the higher resolution
set of variables,
like the periods of operation,
the headway or frequency
of service, route
configuration, stop spacing,
and service type because
of demand response
to all of these factors.
And which factors affect
transit ridership?
We mentioned a few of them.
Broadly speaking,
we can divide them
into two categories--
exogenous factors that are not
under the control of the agency,
and endogenous factors which
the agency has some
degree of control over.
So exogenous factors include
auto ownership and availability
and operating costs.
The cheaper it is to own
and maintain and operate
your own private
automobile, the less likely
you are to take transit.
Fuel prices and
availability, same thing.
Demographics-- it's age,
gender, other income.
All these things affect
ridership and revenues.
And then the activity system.
So tractors, job centers,
population density,
things like that also
are affecting ridership.
So to the degree that there's an
exogenous change in the system,
population, employment
distributions,
these things can influence
ridership, demand
for public transportation.
So usually these
things are assumed
to be fixed in the short run.
And we said that we would
focus on short run predictions.
Often these things are
not considered in models.
Some of them do.
We'll look at some exceptions.
And then there's
endogenous factors.
And these are the ones that an
agency can control, so fare,
the head of way which relates
to how long people have
to wait for service, route
structure which relates
to the walking time, access
and egress times, and the ride
time.
And then there is
crowding and reliability.
So obviously if we
change frequency,
we might change crowding.
And also reliability
through cycle
time and available
recovery time,
as we've seen in
previous lectures.
So crowding is interesting
because as crowding increases,
that makes transit less
comfortable, right?
So that has an impact to,
say, decrease the demand.
And then if demand
is to decrease,
then that would really
reduce crowding.
So there is some sort of loop
there, a causal loop which
reaches some
equilibrium, at least,
when we look at snapshots.
Crowding and reliability
are difficult to measure,
especially reliability
is difficult to measure
without ADL.
And crowding is difficult
to measure without ADC.
So usually these things
are not accounted
for in ridership prediction
models if you look at practice.
These things are often excluded.
They are important, though,
so they do effect demand.
Reliability has a
big impact on demand,
according to revealed
preference studies.
OK, so--
AUDIENCE: Can I--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: In the exogenous
factors of auto availability,
now in this world we're
living where [INAUDIBLE],,
does that fall under
auto availability,
even though it's
not a function--
PROFESSOR: But that is an
exogenous factor, right?
However you want to classify it.
So the question is,
transportation network
companies like Uber and
Lyft and Fasten, et cetera,
all of these companies provide
not necessarily auto ownership.
But they do affect--
they provide a different
mode of transportation
that competes in some
cases and other cases
might complement
public transportation.
So that's an exogenous factor.
It's not necessarily
under the control
of the public
transportation agency.
And therefore it's not--
I haven't seen any demand
model that captures it,
although there is some
research here at MIT that
is trying to look at that
because that's an emerging
trend.
And it's important to see if
we can capture those effects.
AUDIENCE: In certain
places [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: We don't know, right?
We're still investigating.
AUDIENCE: But you
said we consider
those factors to be fixed.
But actually, TNC is
an example of something
which is rather dynamic
in terms of pricing.
PROFESSOR: So I didn't
say that we want
to consider them to be fixed.
I'm saying that if we look at
what happens in practice, what
the models that agencies
have implemented and used
to study, to predict ridership
and revenue, those models,
if you were to go
survey the industry,
and even some models in
academia tend to assume
these things to be fixed.
And part of that has
to do with the fact
that the predictions of interest
are shorter on predictions.
For example, I'm going
to raise fares by $0.25.
So should I include
the effect of TNCs?
Yes or no?
Maybe.
I don't know.
But it could be a factor, right?
So good question.
OK.
So the traditional
approach is reactive.
So if there is an
exogenous change,
the reaction is to
monitor that change
and maybe respond to it in
service planning process.
An endogenous change,
such as a fare increase,
it means that we're sort
of modifying the system
and if we see a
ridership change,
we might then react to
the ridership change.
So it's always catching
up to what we see.
So no attempt to anticipate
impacts prior to the changes.
Current practice,
typically little attention
is paid to the problem in many
public transportation agencies,
unless it's fare increases or
a major capital project, right?
So we just set an example of
TNCs being a different thing.
We haven't really
seen serious attention
until very recently
of what impact that
would have on our ridership.
Typical or traditional planning
models are ineffective.
Generally, they're
not lethal enough
to apply them for a
short run prediction.
So we're thinking here
about four-step modeling.
It's expensive to run.
It takes time.
So for short run
predictions, they
tend not to have
the high [INAUDIBLE]
solution that you need to decide
something about a specific bus
route, for example.
So these are
typically not applied
to specific case studies.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: What is TNC?
PROFESSOR: Transportation
Network Company,
so Uber, Lyft, Via, Fasten,
all these providers.
So ad hoc judgmental
methods dominate.
So now these methods are not
the most accurate, obviously.
But they are useful, especially
if there's a small change
and you have many
proposals on the table,
you have people experienced
with the area or the network.
They might have a good sense
of at least the direction
and the overall level of
change that one might expect.
But they tend to
be quite inaccurate
for disaggregate predictions,
long term predictions, or very
large changes in the network.
So if you're doing
something small, maybe OK.
If you're doing something
significant, not so much.
OK, so we have four approaches
here to modeling, right, is it?
Ordered from in order of
increasing sophistication,
starting with
professional judgment,
then non-committal
survey techniques,
then cross-sectional
data models,
then time series data models.
And let's talk a little
bit about each one.
Professional
judgment, so this is
when you bring in as an
agency either experts
within the agency
or consultants whose
job is to predict ridership.
They have a lot of
experience doing so.
They might have local knowledge.
And of course, the
problem is that there
haven't been any scientific
studies that indicate
the accuracy of these methods.
They tend not to be reproducible
every time you call someone in.
That's sort of a one
shot deal, right?
So you're not really able to
replicate those results easily
or understand what
led to the prediction.
This reflects lack of faith in
formal models in some cases,
lack of data or
technical expertise
to support the
development from all,
or a lack of time
or budget to do so.
And maybe most importantly
relative on importance
of the topic of
ridership prediction
in general to an
agency is compared
to the impact of changes or
impacts on existing ridership.
So agencies tend to worry
more about the reaction
of the public that
currently rides
their service than
the general increase
or decrease in ridership.
Although, they do they
are concerned about that.
They worry more
about the last four.
So any questions on
professional judgment?
We all know what this is, right?
OK.
Survey-based methods, the
next level of sophistication.
So here we go out
and ask people,
would you ride a
bus route if it were
extended to Kendall Square.
Or if we provide
a new train line,
would you do this instead
of driving your own car?
Things like this.
And how much would you pay?
So you can survey
people and ask them,
would you take this or not?
You lay out a proposal and you
ask people for their reaction.
This isn't called
non-committal because people
are saying that they
would do it or not do it.
But they are not
committed to doing so.
And there's no promise
that they will do so.
So the stated
preference might be
quite different from
the revealed preference
if one were to actually follow
up with what these people
actually, the--
question?
AUDIENCE: Is there a sense
of accuracy [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: It varies widely.
And there are many
papers and lots
of studies that
have looked at this.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] can
you just give us a sense?
PROFESSOR: So, yeah, right here.
So typically we have a survey.
You might ask, say, 500
people or 300 people
whether they would
do this or not.
A typical example is a roadside
survey where you stop cars
and you ask them, would
you have taken a park
and ride using the metro
system or an express bus line?
And they would say yes
or no and off you go.
So noncommittal, right?
There's no-- there's no
necessity to actually do
that if you said yes.
So the problem is that there's
this noncommittal bias.
People tend to say yes more
than they would actually do so.
This has to do with sort
of psychological factors.
Sometimes the desire somewhat
subconscious to be friendly--
there is a perception that
the person doing the survey
is interested in
[INAUDIBLE] result.
And therefore, as
human beings, we
try to be friendly or try
to be positive, right?
This is psychological.
It's subconscious.
It affects results.
So what happens--
what ends up happening
is that there's an
adjustment factor
for the non-committal bias.
And this is where professional
judgment comes in.
So you do have some
survey technique.
But at the end, you
need this fudge factor.
You multiply it by anywhere
between 5% and 50%.
And what that range-- what
that specific number is
depends on the specifics of
a problem, who you survey,
how many people you survey,
the experience with the person
conducting the study.
Any questions on
non-committal surveys?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
maybe it could also
be that I would say yes because
I personally wouldn't use it,
but I have a kid
who might use it.
And so I know someone
who would use it.
So I say, yeah, yeah, I use it.
And I might even be--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--blatantly lying about myself.
But I say, oh, well, if
they provide this service,
then my kid will use it.
And so I want to say yes.
PROFESSOR: I'll
repeat the comment
for the benefit of people
listening on the web later on.
So the comment is that another
reason for a noncommittal bias
is that you might know
people who would write it.
Or another instance of
this is, maybe you ask,
would you today have done this?
And maybe today
you wouldn't have,
but you think, typically
I would, right?
So then you want to be helpful
and give what is most typical.
Problem with that is that if
everybody's is doing that,
you have a bias, right?
Because you are doing,
hopefully, a random sample.
So you could have surveyed
my spouse or my kid,
but you didn't.
You picked someone at random.
If everyone you pick is trying
to answer for someone else
or answer for what I would
have done on a different day
and that all leads to a positive
bias, then in aggregate,
you could have a problem.
So it doesn't help if people
are dishonest and trying
to be helpful, right?
Any questions-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is there any way to
randomize the direction
of the question and--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Yes, but that's--
so that's the next method.
So we'll talk about
that right now.
So this is not recommended
because this bias can
be significant and
it's hard to quantify.
Now there's something called
stated preference analysis
or conjoint analysis.
And is where we apply
statistical techniques to try
to correct for that bias.
So this originated in
mathematical psychology.
And what we do is that it's
a rigorous, detailed sign
of the experiment.
And usually what you do is
that instead of asking people
if they would take
this or not, you say,
would you rather take this
option or this option?
And you put some bundles.
And you ask them to trade
them off multiple times.
You say, well, what if
it cost one more dollar?
What if-- and you
have multiple levels.
So people start contradicting
themselves sometimes
in these trade-offs.
And you can detect the biases
using those contradictions,
or at least you can rank
the relative importance
of different factors
to that person
and then apply those factors
to correct for the bias.
So this is, again,
this area's evolving.
It is being applied already
by high end consulting firms
and also by researchers.
So if you find research
papers on the [INAUDIBLE]
stated preference
surveys, you'll
find these kinds of
techniques being applied.
This is very useful for new
services or new service areas.
Why is that?
Why would this technique be
especially useful for that?
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Because there
is an existing status
quo that they're implicitly
comparing against.
PROFESSOR: If there isn't
any service to start with,
you're talking about a new
line or a new area of service
where transit isn't
really present or not
present to the degree
that you're proposing,
then there's no good way of
looking at the existing amount
and extrapolate from there.
So then you have to ask people.
And this is a method to
correct for [INAUDIBLE] bias.
One more comment-- the
MTA useless in the 1980s.
And they concluded
that they would
raise fares to repay
bonds that they
had taken for capital projects.
So it's been applied
successfully.
The next method or
family of methods
is cross-sectional models.
So here we develop
a model of demand
as a function of route
and demographic data
to explain ridership.
So we're looking at a snapshot
at a single point in time
or, say, we pick a period
of three months altogether
and we look at the ridership
over those three months
across different bus
routes in the region.
And then we observe that
different bus routes have
different demand and they
have different frequencies
and they run through sectors
with different population
densities and different
employment densities.
And we tried to relate
the differences in demand
on those routes to the ridership
to those characteristics.
This is called a
cross-sectional model.
So again, we explained
the differences in demand
as a function of the
differences in characteristics.
And there are different
approaches here.
Rules of thumb is the simplest.
So we might say if
it's key bus routes,
then it has this much demand.
That's a very sort of
simple, crude example.
The similar routes
method is I'm going
to convert this bus route to--
I'm going to add
frequency to it,
say, increase its frequency.
And then it's going to look a
lot more like this other bus
route that I have in
another part of the network.
So ridership should look
a lot more like that.
Maybe I separate my bus
routes in the network
into high ridership
key bus routes
that have certain high frequency
and other less frequent bus
routes that run on less
dense parts of the network.
And I take those
averages and I apply
them to extrapolate, right?
So that's a similar route.
You find similar routes.
You use those to
make a prediction.
Then there's the multiple
factor trip rate model.
You, again, look at--
you do a regression, maybe.
You can do this with regression
or by separate factors.
So those are the last
two bullets here.
So you essentially run
regression where you have--
maybe you load up
a GIS layer and you
have population density,
employment density, frequency.
And out of the regression
comes these factors
where you can control
for multiple factors
at the same time.
Any questions on
cross-sectional methods?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Because
these models generally
focus only on endogenous
factors and not
exogenous, so they
don't physically
capture the demand, how
the demand is [INAUDIBLE]
with difference
to other factors.
So how can this be generalized
so that second point is
that similar routes--
like, it can be generalized.
One that uses less data or
is shallow in its nature
could not generally
be generalized, right?
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Yes.
These models are hard to
generalize because they don't--
actually, any cross-sectional
model is hard to generalize,
right?
Because you are looking
at a specific time
window of analysis.
So you are already,
in doing so, excluding
any longer-term trends
that are often exogenous,
like fuel prices and population
changes and things like that.
So yes, by doing a
model, even the most
sophisticated of these, which
is a multivariate regression
model, if you have any
factors that you leave out,
that can lead to biases
in the estimators, right?
So will you actually
see that bias?
Well, that depends on how
short run of a prediction
are you trying to do?
Is your prediction
going to be applied
to a period in the
short term that
is very similar
to the period you
have now where these exogenous
factors have been out,
have not changed,
and therefore there
is no impact on the
bias of this model.
Or are you going to apply this--
abuse this, let's
say, misapply it--
abuse it to predict
outside of that window,
outside of that domain,
where you do have changes
that you did not
include in the model,
and they have
affected ridership?
Yes.
Any other questions about
cross-sectional methods?
OK.
Let's move on.
A little bit about regression.
So this is an example of
how an agency might respond
to increases in demand by
increasing frequency and vise
versa.
So you look at--
you start with an observation
that ridership is quite high
and the frequency is
some amount right now.
And then you react to that.
So as an agency, you might
say, well, this bus route
is quite crowded,
therefore, let's increase
the frequency, right?
And let's increase
the frequency.
That's going to have an
effect on the demand curve.
So all of these lines,
d, are demand curves.
And this demand curve shows
the response of ridership
to a change in
frequency, assuming
everything else stays the same.
But there are also other changes
that are not included here.
So you might increase
frequency but there
might be other exogenous
factors, exogenous in this case
because frequency is the only
variable being shown here.
Any other variable
that increases demand
will not result in a change
along the demand curve.
It will actually shift
the demand curve, right?
So you have demand curves
going in a third dimension,
increasing demand in a third
dimension due to other factors.
So typically, again,
agencies are reactive.
They sort of observe an increase
then they move to the next one
and they're always
thinking about one demand
curve, if at all.
And so it's better
for this reason
to look at multiple factors at
the same time instead of just
one factor, such as frequency.
OK, so these are some
typical transit elasticities.
We have elasticities
to fare, to headway,
and to total travel time here.
And so these are
the typical values
if you look at many
studies and take averages,
this is what you find.
So elasticity to
fare, negative 0.3.
Let's do a quick recap.
What is elasticity?
Henry?
AUDIENCE: Percent
change in demand
over percent change in price.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's-- so the answer is
percent change in demand over
percent change in price.
I want to make two adjustments
to that definition.
That's often how
it's calculated.
But it's actually the derivative
of the curve, not necessarily
a percent change.
That is an approximation
of the derivative.
And the other is that
it's not just to price.
In this case, we're
looking at change
to fare towards headway or
to other disutilities, so
any other factor that
affects disutility.
So what is the
difference between--
what is negative elasticity?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: As all those
variables are going up,
your ridership is going down.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So as fare increases,
the ridership goes down.
Great.
What is the meaning
of an elasticity
with an absolute value
between 0 and 1 instead
of greater than 1?
Or, rather, what
is the difference
between an elasticity that has
absolute value less than one
versus one that has an absolute
value greater than one?
AUDIENCE: Relatively inelastic?
PROFESSOR: OK, so--
AUDIENCE: So for example--
PROFESSOR: --inelastic
versus elastic.
Those are the terms used to
explain the differences, right?
So what is an elastic change?
AUDIENCE: A change in
price would not necessarily
diminish the demands from the
quantities demanded by people.
You could have--
PROFESSOR: Is this fair
value of [INAUDIBLE]
inelastic or elastic?
AUDIENCE: Elastic.
PROFESSOR: This is inelastic.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Yeah, inelastic, yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
this is inelastic.
So what does that
mean in practice?
AUDIENCE: A change in fare--
PROFESSOR: So I know that--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --would not lead to an
equivalent change in ridership.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: It would lead to
less than the equivalent change
in ridership.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Therefore if you
increase fares, you
will lose some
ridership, but not enough
to lose total [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Right?
If this volume were greater
than-- have an absolute value
greater than 1, then
you might actually
decrease-- the response
in the [INAUDIBLE]
might be so strong that you
might end up loosing revenue
because the amount
is so much lower.
So if you overprice an item
by a lot and nobody buys it,
you might end up
getting less, right?
In transit, typical
[INAUDIBLE] are inelastic.
So this is important.
This means that
any transit agency
who needs more federal
revenue can probably
increase fares and know that
they will get more money.
That's sort of one that
keeps conclusions of this.
The range of these values
is from negative 0.1
to negative 0.5.
The elasticity of headway is
a little larger in magnitude.
So the response of
demand to frequency
is stronger a little bit
than the response to fares,
and often overlooked
in ridership spikes.
And then total travel time,
people respond very strongly
to that.
So
OK, then there are these
important other points
that I want to go through.
Small cities have larger fare
elasticities than large cities.
Let's talk about each one and
suggest the reasons for them.
So why would small cities
have larger elasticities?
AUDIENCE: The absolute value?
PROFESSOR: Yes, absolute value.
So you're saying that they
are more elastic, right?
AUDIENCE: More sensitive.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, more sensitive.
So small cities--
ridership in small cities
is more sensitive than
ridership in large cities.
AUDIENCE: There's
not as much of a--
there's not as much
utility lost by switching
two different modes.
There might not be as much
traffic if you drive instead.
Some fare might be more of a
reason that people that use it.
And also that parking
might not be as costly
so that if you raise
the fare a little bit,
you might get more
expensive than parking.
PROFESSOR: OK, so you have
other sort of characteristics
in large cities that you
don't find in small cities,
such as parking costs.
AUDIENCE: That
would be a way of--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: I'm trying to
summarize it, and also
repeat for posterity.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Also in urban cities,
since these elasticities are
being computed for the
population as a whole,
there are more people dependent
on the mass transit system.
PROFESSOR: That
is very important.
This is one of the key factors
affecting this, actually.
So you have a much
larger dependence
on public transportation
in large cities.
And also-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is it really
the size of the city or
is it the density of the city--
PROFESSOR: It's
probably density.
These are correlated.
So maybe this could have
been more carefully chosen.
And you could say
older cities, as well.
I would argue older pre-auto
industry, pre-highway expansion
cities as another way
of putting footings.
Yes?
More ideas about this?
Henry?
AUDIENCE: I don't know
how you're defining this--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Someone first--
PROFESSOR: Henry.
OK.
You decide.
AUDIENCE: I was
just curious about,
how do you define small cities?
Because for example, I'm
thinking in my own country,
a small city would be a city of
around 200,000, 100,000 people.
And over there, for example,
an increase in the fare
would have this characteristic
because you can still
walk [INAUDIBLE].
So walking is still an option.
And I think it's kind
of correlated with what
you were saying about
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: So all
of these things
have to do with
where you apply them.
And maybe they're not
completely generalizable.
But I think this
observation has more
to do with the North American
and European context.
So but that's a
good observation.
Henry?
AUDIENCE: I think
smaller cities also
have less extensive coverage.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so our imports--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --are already
trained to not rely on--
PROFESSOR: So the public
transportation supply
might be quite undesirable
or inefficient.
And so therefore--
AUDIENCE: And if you
jack up the price,
that will make it
less desirable.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
OK, great.
OK, let's move to the next one.
Bus travel is more
elastic than commuter rail
rapid rail travel.
AUDIENCE: Simply, bus travel
is smaller traveled distance
and there are possible
another alternatives.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's the key reason.
So if you have a
shorter distance,
and bus travel tends
to be shorter distance,
then you are more likely
to have other options,
whereas commuter rail, you
might be able to drive maybe
your own car, so et cetera.
So there are fewer options
in general to the public
for a longer distance travel.
And commuter rail
and rapid rail travel
tends to be longer distance.
AUDIENCE: Commuter rail, rapid
rail, certainly in Russia,
have a time advantage, tend
to have a time advantage
over the private vehicle.
PROFESSOR: That's true, as well.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
This is another reason--
AUDIENCE: The bus never has--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: --competitiveness
of the mode in rush hour
where buses might be
stuck in traffic and rail
is not stuck in traffic, right?
So that drives the
elasticity more
because so many more people
are traveling in rush hours.
Great.
Let's move on to the third
one, off peak fare elasticities
are double the size of
peak fare elasticities.
Lee.
AUDIENCE: The difference between
leisure and business travelers
where you can change
your trip decision
if it's a leisure trip, but
not if you're going to work.
PROFESSOR: Trip purpose, right?
So peak travel tends to have a
higher proportion of business
and you don't have the
option of not doing the trip.
So you must do the trip.
What else?
Something related to that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Again,
congestion has a role.
To consider the idea of
commuting by Uber in New York
City, it might not make sense
to do that during a peak period
if you're going to be sitting
in traffic on the road
and the subway has,
then, a time advantage.
But returning home late in the
evening, that time advantage
of transit could be
eroded because there's
less congestion.
PROFESSOR: Right, so congestion
can have a major effect.
And congestion is
larger at peak.
And therefore, it
could make modes
that are segregated have
their own right of way more--
so related to the previous one.
What else?
Eli.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I think
it was discretionary ridership
during--
PROFESSOR: Very important, yeah.
So can you elaborate?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
During the off peak
hours, you have
more people who
have no other choice
to get around, use transit.
PROFESSOR: And why not?
Why might these people
not have other choices?
AUDIENCE: Because
they are lower income.
PROFESSOR: Lower income, right.
So lower income people who
work may have no other options.
This may be the only
option they can afford.
And therefore, they
are less sensitive.
So if you raise fares, well,
it doesn't look good for them.
But that's the only
alternative for them.
So they'll react.
Great.
Short distance trips are more
elastic than long distance
trips.
We already covered that
in the context of rail,
so let's skip that.
Fare elasticities
rise with income.
This should be straightforward.
AUDIENCE: More options
if you have more income.
PROFESSOR: If you have more
income, you have more options.
You can afford all
the other options.
So there you go.
And what about fare
elasticities fall with age?
So older people,
senior people are less
sensitive to changes in fair.
Why is that?
Emily?
AUDIENCE: Higher
income [INAUDIBLE]..
They tend to have fewer options.
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: Because, well,
walking might not be an option.
PROFESSOR: So the active
modes might be less desirable?
AUDIENCE: They might not have
a driver's license anymore.
PROFESSOR: They may not
be-- have a driver's license
anymore.
AUDIENCE: They might
have failing vision
and therefore not be able
to drive or have other--
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
OK.
Of all trip purposes, the work
trip is the most inelastic.
We've covered that.
And then promotional
fare elasticities
are slightly larger
than short term fare
elasticities following
permanent fare additions.
So--
AUDIENCE: Can you explain that?
What does promotion--
PROFESSOR: So if you
do a free fare day
and you put ads everywhere
or something like this.
The response that
you will get is
going to be much stronger than
if you are on a routine basis
raise fares and--
yeah.
So why does that happen?
AUDIENCE: Maybe the increase
in demand due to the lower--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Increase if you
reduce them or decrease
if you increase them, right?
AUDIENCE: If you
increase fares, they--
Better promotional if you
have lower fare, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But we can extend this to how
frequently this change happens
and how much buzz is there
about the spare change.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: People feel like,
oh, it's happening once.
I've got to do it
now, or I won't--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the
psychological effects
of marketing, the
effectiveness of marketing on--
so if you look at agencies that
every year at a certain dates
raise their fares more
or less with inflation,
there's much less sort of the
reaction-- the public reaction
is much lower.
So--
AUDIENCE: Are those
promotional fare--
free fare day, free fair
weekend, are they effective?
Does anyone--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: That's what
your goal is, right?
AUDIENCE: No, the goal is--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: But it might
be effective at increasing
ridership temporarily if you
have some event on the city
and you want to--
if you want people to use
those modes instead of drive,
that might be a success.
So you want to increase
the efficiency of vehicles
by decreasing load
times so people
don't have to interact
with a fare box,
you can open all doors.
People go in and out.
That might be a success.
So--
AUDIENCE: Paris once
did that for exposure,
to try to lure people in
because they already--
yeah.
But the question
is, is it effective?
PROFESSOR: Well, again,
it depends on what
your measures of success are.
Emily?
AUDIENCE: Also,
promotional fares
might attract more discretionary
trips than people--
PROFESSOR: People might say,
oh, I want to try this, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Whereas permanent
fare revisions tend
to effect people who are
just doing their commute.
PROFESSOR: And therefore--
AUDIENCE: Who are
therefore less--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if you do any
kind of promotion,
you might make people that tend
not to even be aware of transit
fares be aware of this option.
And so you might lure them in.
Yeah, Henry?
AUDIENCE: There are
also a lot of cities
that do free transit
on New Years Eve
to reduce drunk driving--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So that's another example.
So on New Year's Eve,
to reduce drunk driving,
offer free fares.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it's safe to say
that promotional fares are only
useful for short-term
effects but they
don't have any effect on
long-term [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: I don't want
to make that broad claim,
but I think I agree
with the premise of it.
OK.
OK, let's revisit a model that
we saw on an earlier lecture.
This is the TTC elasticity
model, which we saw is used
or has been used to predict
the rider changes to service
changes, so ridership
response to service changes.
So this is the-- let's recount.
The total weighted
travel time is
a sum of four components--
the in-vehicle travel
time, the waiting time,
the walking time, which
is the access and egress
and transfer time,
and a penalty for the number
of transfers that you have
to take for that [INAUDIBLE].
And then there
are these weights.
1.5, so what does that
mean, 1.5 in this equation?
I'll generalize this
utility equation,
a systematic
disutility equation.
It has some factors before each
of the explanatory variables.
Sonia?
AUDIENCE: People hate waiting.
So it is extra--
PROFESSOR: How much more
do they hate waiting?
AUDIENCE: They hate
waiting 1.5 times as much
as they hate being
in their vehicle.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Exactly.
So now these numbers
are nice and round.
So TTC did not conduct a
revealed preference study
to estimate it from data.
But they align somewhat well
with revealed preference
studies.
So the order of magnitude,
at least, is correct.
I've seen factors as
high as 3 for waiting
time, as low as one, in cases
of rush hour and, say, metro.
So that gives you a range.
Walking, I've seen 5, 10.
I've seen higher.
But penalties for
number of transfers,
I've seen five
minutes, 10 minutes.
So people hate transferring.
This is the street bound.
So this is 10 minutes for every
transfer you have to make.
Great, so what happens?
You compute the total weighted
travel time before and after.
So you have the
current situation
and then you have a proposal
that will alter these values
and result in a new total
weighted travel time.
And then we apply
some elasticities.
So these elasticities
defer by period.
So during the peak,
we have negative 1.5.
Mid-day, we have
a higher response.
This aligns with
what we just said.
Peak period ridership
tends to be more inelastic.
So we have a stronger response
during the middle of the day.
And if you look at early
in the morning or evening,
even stronger.
So you have higher values.
Question, why are
these values have
a [INAUDIBLE] greater than one?
This is a trick
question, in some sense.
AUDIENCE: Travel time is--
ridership is dependent
on travel time.
It's very elastic.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that's one way of putting it.
So I guess the observation
is like, these are now
fair elasticities.
And they are not
frequency elasticities.
They are elasticities of
total weighted travel time.
And these are four
components coming together
and we can't really
think about it
in terms of fare elasticity
and single variable, really.
These are multiple
effects coming together.
So great.
So do we understand
how this applies?
We have a service proposal.
We estimate the
effects on riderships
in [INAUDIBLE] waiting time,
walking time, and number
of transfers.
We know how many people would
ride before and after, or we--
well, we don't know that.
We want to predict
that, but we know
for each [INAUDIBLE] how
each of these components
would be affected.
And then we use the
[INAUDIBLE] elasticities
to predict the change.
OK?
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Is the 10 in front
of in trans, does
that mean the average
transfer is 10 minutes,
or does this mean people
just really, really
don't like transfers because
they want a simple route?
PROFESSOR: So this
excludes waiting time.
This is the fact that I have to
transfer is so annoying that I
would rather spend--
or it would be the same as
spending extra 10 minutes
in a vehicle.
If you would give me a situation
where I have a single ride
option that takes
10 minutes longer
and you gave me another one
that takes 10 minutes less
but I have to
transfer, I wouldn't
know which one to take.
They would be equally
desirable or undesirable.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would you
say that in a more--
if this was a more
distinct model,
then the penalty for
transferring rail to rail would
be less than the penalty
for transferring--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, of course.
You could make this
much more sophisticated.
And you could say, are
there escalators or not?
You know, you could argue,
are some parts of the city,
say, less safe, and
therefore walking time
is very undesirable,
especially at night?
So you could really go
disaggregate and apply
all these behavioral impacts.
So yeah, you can make
this more sophisticated.
But you have the idea, right?
This is an
elasticity-based model.
OK.
Direct demand regression
models, again, we
covered a little bit of this.
We match census tract data to
route service characteristics.
This is hard without GIS tools.
GIS is a geographical
information system
where you have a
map and you load
layers of data showing
things geographically
like population density
and a point of density.
Your bus stops, your bus
lines, your train lines.
So we use GIS tools to apportion
population and employment
data to different bus routes.
So you know that the bus route
goes along these centers that
have certain properties.
Then we run a
regression of trying
to explain ridership
as a function
of those characteristics.
And often what
happens is that you
have large or high
significance of dummy variables
and track-specific constants.
So the general variables
like frequency,
the variables that apply to
all the bus routes together,
tend to be maybe not as
significant statistically
as these very specific
variables that apply only
to one or two bus routes.
And that means
that in some sense,
we are specifying a
model that is over fitted
and there are some
issues with this.
So the other issue is
that these models tend
not to recognize
network interactions,
or they never do, rather,
because if you have two bus
lines running through the
same employment center
and going to two
different places,
both at the same
frequency, then presumably
they should share the demand
from that employment center,
right?
If you only had one
bus route and you
leave the
characteristics the same,
then that ridership
would be a lot higher.
This model doesn't
really account
for that, the complementarity
or competition
of the supply in the network.
So that's an issue.
And then the relationship
between supply and demand
is not--
the interaction is not captured.
So we can-- there are
alternative approaches.
Simultaneous equation models
are capable of addressing
the relationship between
supply and demand.
And then some other
models are able to capture
the relationship between
competing and complementary
routes.
And we'll look at an example.
That's the logical next step
beyond direct demand models.
And then the full network
models which sort of
have-- you have the GIS.
You have all the network.
Those deal explicitly with
competing complementary routes
because people in that mall
have the option of any bus route
and they see all their options.
And in these models
you can include
[INAUDIBLE] distribution
of model split effect.
So that's the next step beyond--
the logical next step
beyond the TTC-type model--
the elasticity model
that we just discussed.
Both of these require GIS--
some computer representation
of the transit network
and the service area.
This used to be a challenge.
Not so much anymore.
Most agencies put out
TTFS data and write layers
showing where
their bus stops are
and so this is now commonplace.
This is not an obstacle anymore.
Questions about this?
Henry?
AUDIENCE: What is TTC?
PROFESSOR: Oh, the Toronto
Transit Commission.
It's the bus agency
in [INAUDIBLE]..
Other questions?
OK, so let's look at a
simultaneous equation model.
So here we have ridership of
some route, I, on some segment,
Z. So we divide up bus
routes into segments.
And we have many bus
routes and many segments.
And we say that is a function of
the level of service provided.
So think of that as
frequency, the level
of service provided on that
bus route on that zone,
and other external factors.
Those external factors
are demographics,
socioeconomic
characteristics of ridership,
the population density, things
like that, so maybe exogenous.
Then you say supply,
on the other hand,
so my level of service, is a
function of the ridership I
have right now because
if I have more riders,
I will provide more service.
Also, it is a
reaction to ridership
as it was in the past.
And it's also a reaction
to other external factors.
So these two equations
are simultaneous.
You have to solve
them at the same time.
And they could take
different functional forms.
We are specifying here at
a sort of conceptual level.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, is that in the
second version, is it a typo
or do we actually consider
the overall ridership
in the previous time period?
PROFESSOR: It
could be a function
of the ridership in the past.
In other words, this is a way
of saying, my supply right now,
my supply today, is a function
of what ridership used to be.
AUDIENCE: No, what I mean
is, should that be segment
dependent or do we then scale it
up to the entire [INAUDIBLE]----
PROFESSOR: Oh, it could be
segment dependent or not.
So you're saying why not have z?
You could.
If you want to add
it in, go ahead.
Again, this is conceptual.
So what I'm saying is this
is not a specific model.
Rather, this is a
conceptual description
of how you set up a
simultaneous equation model.
So the point of that
variable is to say
that you could include
the effects of previously
observed ridership.
So don't think about this as
a specification of a model.
I'll put this on Cellar.
This is the paper that
describes this in detail
if you want to look at the
specifics of such a model.
Here's an example from
Portland Tri-Met on that paper.
You have route 19 and route 20
which were on, in this diagram,
kind of east-west.
So route 19 runs along
this line right here.
And for each bus route we
have a [INAUDIBLE] area.
So route 19 captures
this part on top and also
this middle part that
is shaded both ways.
Another is route 20, which
runs along this line.
And it captures people here
and also people in this area.
So this area in the middle is--
people from that area go
to route 19 or route 20.
So in that area, route
19 and 20 are competing.
Then they kind of merge
and go through zone 0
and they are fully competing.
They are-- maybe it's a
branch and trunk system.
And then there are these
other bus routes, route 70,
route 75, 21, and 22, that
are across South-North,
North-South, that corridor.
And we say that
these bus routes are
complementary because
people might transfer,
people going from
somewhere on the south
might transfer to one of
these route 19 or route 20.
So the fact that route
70 or 75 is there,
it means that people
get-- more than not
will be attracted
to the corridor.
So then we quantify the degree
to which bus routes compete
with this overlapping
population fraction
percentage or proportion.
So this is the percentage of
the fraction of population
that is on the
overlapping portion.
So we look at route
length in route 20.
We're saying how much relation
is on this overlapping
area divided by the sum of the
population captured by route 19
and the sum of population
captured by route 20?
So that gives you an idea
of the degree of overlap.
We also measure population
in each catchment area
for each bus route.
And we can then capture
inter-route effects.
So we do that by modifying
the equation two slides ago
and adding this
third question here.
So before we have ridership as
a function of level of service
and external factors.
Now we're adding the ridership
on competing bus routes.
So these are bus routes that are
competing on the same segment.
And they run with
overlapping population.
So to the extent
that this increases,
the ridership on
Route I decreases.
And then we also
consider the ridership
on complementary routes
across this catchment area.
And to the extent
that this increases,
the ridership on
route I increases.
We also consider the degree
of population overlap
and the external factors.
Again, this is conceptual.
If you want to look
at the specifics,
I suggest you look
at the readings.
I will post the paper.
So this is a way of modeling
the effects of complementarity
and competition.
OK, a different
approach, moving down
the list of sophistication
of modeling approaches
is the network-based
modeling analysis approach.
So here we have a transit origin
destination matrix as an input.
We measure how people are
using the system right now.
We have layer like a DTFS layer
with the base transit network.
And we put that into a model.
And then we tell that model,
we're going to make a change.
We're going to add
a bus line or we're
going to increase
frequency or we're
fares, whatever it is.
And that model will look at
the current transit demand
and predict changes.
OK?
So that's the general idea.
It'll also output not
just ridership and revenue
but things like
rider attributes.
You might have information about
income and things in GIS layers
that can be allocated
to different services.
And there are three levels
of analysis for how to use--
three levels of detail
on the OD matrix.
The first one is
fixed transit flows.
So again, in order
of sophistication,
starting with the least
sophisticated, fixed transit
flow.
So we look at the current
transit relief flow.
This could be from
a telephone survey
or from any kind of survey.
Or we have, now,
modern techniques
based on AFC and
inference models
that we will discuss shortly
in the next few lectures.
So we have the OE matrix,
current OE matrix for transit.
And we assume that
the demand for transit
won't change as a
result of the service
changes in the short run.
So that could be a
strong assumption.
That's typically what we do.
That's typically how
these models work.
Again, we're more
interested in the impacts
on sort of current riders
than on big changes.
The next approach is to say
the total demand is fixed
if I look at the demand
across all modes,
including car and bike and
TNCs and all these things.
So that you have to get from
surveys, the kinds of surveys
that are used to input data
into a four-step model.
But then you allow the
model split to change.
So as a result of
service changes,
people might switch
between modes.
They might go from transit to
car or from car to transit.
So that's preferable, especially
if you have significant service
changes.
But it's not often put in place.
And then there's the
variable total [INAUDIBLE]..
Now you require all
the steps of modeling,
the four-step modeling.
And you are essentially
allowing the total demand
to increase or decrease as
a result of service changes
or fare changes.
Typically no one does this.
And one could argue
this is unnecessary.
Why?
Because we are looking
at short-run changes.
And total demand
shouldn't change
in a very short horizon
as a result of at least
the typical service changes.
So this kind of
model is great if you
want to capture the influence
of land use patterns
on long term
demand, for example.
If, however, you were to
bring in a new rail line that
connects two employment centers,
that's a change in land use.
If you somehow think
that some change
that you will do in your
city, on your transit network,
will bring in a
change in population
or a change in where
people live significantly,
then you have to do this.
That's the only case where
this would be useful.
Otherwise, you probably are
thinking in the short run
total the amount is the same.
People might switch
between modes.
So you will get step two.
And if it's a very
small change, you
could even get away
with step one, where
you look at current demand
and people might change
when they make the trip or
what bus route or rail line
they choose, but not necessarily
the level of ridership.
OK, there's different modeling
and analysis packages.
Let's show three of them.
MADITUC, EMME/2, and TrainsCAD.
Have anybody heard
of any of these?
Raise your hand.
OK, about half of you.
Great.
So let's start with MADITUC.
It was developed in Montreal.
It was a common
technique in Montreal.
It requires only survey data
that includes route choice
information.
So this is a line level
model, essentially.
It's designed for
transit service planning
and it uses all or
nothing assignments.
So it looks at, for
a given [INAUDIBLE],,
which is the best
path on the network.
And then it puts all of the
people on the [INAUDIBLE]
into that one path.
So everybody makes the same
decision kind of thing.
And it doesn't have built-in
data analysis or a graphics
capability.
So you take the output of it
and you put it somewhere else.
These people were using
SAS and other software
to generate graphics
and to generate plots
and calculated statistics.
It's been used in four
of the Canadian cities--
Montreal, Quebec,
Toronto, and Winnipeg.
And here's an output from
of that data, plotted
with a different software.
So this is-- you can sort of
see the business plot of OD.
I'm not sure,
actually, how it's--
if it's destinations for a
given origin or what it is.
It might just be--
oh, this is number of entries.
Yeah.
I don't know French.
But if anybody--
AUDIENCE: It's number
of entries by foot or--
PROFESSOR: On foot.
AUDIENCE: On foot?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What is that?
I don't know that last word.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Anyway.
And then it says AMP 629, right?
OK, great.
EMME/2.
So this is multi-modal
equilibrium.
It was also developed
in Montreal.
It's a little more
sophisticated.
It was developed with the
general regional transportation
modeling package.
It can generate transit OD
flows from a travel demand
model, which the other package
needed that as an input.
It has a link node oriented
approach instead of a line
level approach.
So you can have bus
stops and you can--
it has more detail, [INAUDIBLE].
There are two options
for a transit assignment.
There's aggregate zone to zone,
flow, multi-path assignment.
So that's usually
not precise enough
because it's zone to zone.
And then there's a disaggregate
point-to-point trip assignment
procedure, which you
could know which bus stops
and lines and everything.
It is probabilistic
or multi-path.
So now you have an OD pair and
different alternatives of how
to get from both O to D.
And one may be preferable,
but people might be split
on which lines they take.
And more, maybe 2/3
of people go one way,
and a third go the other.
And some equilibrium
is reached this way.
It's a standalone package.
This has all the
graphics built in.
And here's a picture.
So yeah.
The TransCAD, this
is much more local.
It's over caliber
develops in Newton.
It has good tools to
edit transit networks.
It has an API that allows
you to add your own models.
So if you have your own model
split model, you can put it in.
It has good interactive
computer graphics,
database, built-in database.
It has a network
assignment procedure,
lots of display options
and output formats
and very general purpose.
So typically, you use a transit
network database for this.
So that means geocoded
transit links and nodes.
You have mappings
of transit lines
onto network links and nodes.
So you have essentially
a street network, right?
And you say, this
bus route goes from--
along these road links,
crossing these intersections.
And transit lines are
modeled with some attributes.
So headway is by service period.
Travel times, models,
mode of service or bus,
subway, et cetera.
And there's also
system attributes,
like operating cost data, energy
consumption data, and fares.
Some of this is--
well, these things are put in.
And they then are used
to compute outputs.
So hybrid outputs.
So you get ridership by link
and by line, boardings by node,
by line, by link.
You can have OD travel
times, so in-vehicle
time and also including the
access and egress portions,
transfers, et cetera.
Revenue predictions,
operating cost predictions,
energy consumption predictions,
even CO2 emission predictions,
revenues, operating
costs, characteristics.
And you have all sorts of ways
of displaying that-- tables,
reports, plots, et cetera.
So how about transit
route assignment?
How do we go about that?
So transit route
assignment is the process
by which we assign
origin-destination flows
to specific paths on
the transit network.
So there are two
ways of doing that.
There's an all or
nothing assignment,
which we talked about.
That's the example of MADITUC.
And then there's the
multipath assignment, which
we gave an example for EMME/2.
When would all or
nothing be OK to apply?
If you have not two dense of
a network and not too many
alternatives, right?
Then some networks,
there's only one sort
of feasible, logical
path that one
would take for a given OD pair.
But if you look at a dense
network, say, London,
there are often for an OD
pair multiple good ways
of traveling that OD fare.
And therefore, that
would not be a good model
to use because the flows on
each link might be way off.
Is that understood,
difference between multipath
and all or nothing?
OK.
Another way of dividing
these or categorizing these
is aggregate and disaggregate.
So we also looked at these
in the context of EMME/2.
So aggregate is zone to zone
based on zone centroids.
So you have [INAUDIBLE] of
transportation and ultra zones
or census tracts.
And you look at demand
at that block level.
Or you have disaggregate.
So if you load a
DTFS layer, you have
sort of stop level, line
level, much more precise,
high resolution output
on where the demand would
be assigned to, OK?
And how do we go
about more choice
and sometimes how
do you go about even
assignment to specific lines
or options within the transit
mode?
Often with logit
mode choice model.
So I think most--
well, some of you--
anyone who took 201 or is
taking 202 has seeen this?
Raise your hands if you've
seen what a logit mode choice
model, if you're familiar
with discreet choice modeling
at all, have heard about it?
OK.
So it was something what--
I could see some shy hands that
I know are more exposed to it.
So in this kind of model, the--
when you specify systematic
utility equations
where we say for each
of the alternatives
that this person has,
there are some variables.
These variables include travel
time, cost, reliability, fare,
anything, right?
And the differences
between the alternatives
are explained in terms
of those variables.
And then what we get out
of-- so we run a regression.
It's not linear regression.
It's a different
kind of regression.
And what we get out of
that is the probability--
so we get some system--
we get some parameter
estimates, beta.
And we can use those to
calculate the probability
that an individual will
take some of the options
that we listed rather than
the others that were listed.
So there's a very good
course taught here
at MIT, 1202, demand modeling.
If you're interested in this
topic, I recommend you take it.
And it's taught in
the spring only.
So yeah, so this is obviously
[INAUDIBLE] probability
that [INAUDIBLE]
you would choose
one mode and not the other.
Often, this is
the structure that
is underneath the
TransCAD mode choice
model or anything like that.
And it's great if you
understand how it works.
And if you can build
your own and put it
in there, even better.
So all right.
And what are typical
variables included
in these systematic utility
equations for, say, the work
trip?
Well, it would be travel time,
out of pocket travel costs,
vehicle travel time, income,
gender, auto availability,
and occupation.
So some of these are
traveler characteristics
which vary by person surveyed.
So typically, you will survey
and you collect information
on income, gender, things
that vary by person.
And then you also collect
or put in characteristics
of the choices or the
options other person has.
And both of these
go into the model,
both the decision
maker characteristics
and the options characteristics.
And sometimes we defer those
two by calling one attribute
and the other characteristic.
OK, that's it for
ridership prediction.
But if you have
questions, let's discuss.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What level of modeling
is the T doing for their--
and do they change their bus
network to match their modeling
or is it sort of a longer-term--
PROFESSOR: The T has a
model called [INAUDIBLE],,
which is an elasticity-based
model with market segmentation.
So we talked about--
that was mentioned
earlier in the lecture.
So they split population
by type of fare product.
So people with passes might--
that's a proxy for, say,
frequent riders and those
who might have--
those people might have
different elasticities
than people that
are less frequent
or people that pay
cash or people, right?
So you split people into--
you segment the market,
then you look at--
it looks at previous
fare increases
and it calculates
the elasticities
for each of those
market segments
across several time
periods and everything.
So then it calculates the total
change in ridership and revenue
and also any changes across
would somebody now take,
let's say, would some
people switch to paths
or not switch to paths.
The Transit Hub has done
some research on it.
And some of the people who--
one of the persons who worked
on their research here at MIT
now works at CTPS.
And he's one of the people
who applied the model.
And then I think
for other products,
it depends on the product.
So certainly, there is kind
of the regional long term
planning, which is more
four-step modeling approach.
If there is any
specific project,
I haven't seen what they've done
for the green line expansion.
Ari, do you know?
You always know something.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I--
it's the [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: So that's the
professional judgment?
AUDIENCE: That is a completely
non-professional judgment.
I don't--
PROFESSOR: Does anybody
know what they've done
for the green line extension?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I'm sure
they had to do something.
PROFESSOR: Often these
capital [INAUDIBLE]
require demand analysis.
So I'm sure they
did some modeling.
I'm not sure to what degree.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So whether the modeling
of the FTA requires
is the best one is
subject to discussion.
And I think a lot of
transportation experts
have issues with it.
It tends to put a
lot of weight on--
if you save many people one
second, then that's great.
And instead of being sort
of goal-oriented, and--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I feel
like often agencies
will do one analysis
for their grant
and then their own
analysis because they
think they have benefits.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So, any other comments or
questions on ridership?
This is an important
topic, right?
It's one of the key topics
in public transportation.
If it's a new system, how
many people will ride it?
And therefore, what
mode will I choose?
How much will it cost, or
many, many applications.
Ari?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
guess, maybe could you
speak to how well models do?
Do we have evidence that
models are good, models are--
how-- what are some--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I haven't actually seen--
I'm not very familiar
with any study that
systematically looked at that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: But again,
what we have seen a lot
of is the earlier approaches.
And these sort of
fudge factors put
in, so the 50% stated preference
without conjoint analysis,
things like that.
And those are all
over the map in terms
of whether they were accurate
or not, often because often they
overshoot the prediction.
And you wonder, to
what extent is that
a bias because you
want funding and you
want to show that there will
be ridership for it if it's
a capital project?
But I haven't really seen--
and maybe it exists--
a systematic look at recent
models and how accurate
they were.
AUDIENCE: You mostly see it
for new systems and extensions,
not for existing
service changes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm sort of interested
not in comparing models
to what happens in reality but
what we talked about an hour
ago about surveys, how stated
preference surveys compared
to real preference surveys, if--
has anyone done any
significant research
about a project that was open?
What did people say
before about the moment
that they were going to use it?
What did people then say after
about what mode did I use?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I can't site specific results
because I don't remember them.
But that has been looked at.
And there is research on the
literature on that topic.
AUDIENCE: Isn't there generally
pretty bad follow-up, though,
when--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --these demand models
are done, there is very poor--
PROFESSOR: But I
think generally--
AUDIENCE: They don't
actually predict--
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's true.
So usually once you do a
study, you predict the demand.
If the party goes
forward, nobody
bothers to compare
how bad it was often,
at least not formally.
I'm sure people comment,
gee, that was way off
or that was great.
But do we have sort of
documented studies showing
how well or how accurate
were these predictions?
I haven't really
seen many of them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
newspapers.
And [INAUDIBLE] what
we do with that?
Should we require
follow-up and then if--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--portion of the grant you got?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well,
and maybe it would
allow us to say, OK,
which models have--
where have the
models worked well?
Where have they not worked well?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, the idea of having a
disincentive for overshooting
is interesting.
AUDIENCE: The price is right.
If you consistently
overshoot, we'll
penalize you in the future.
PROFESSOR: So that would
maybe put you on a position
where you want to be as
accurate as possible.
AUDIENCE: But then you might
be too conservative, maybe.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It could be either way, right?
You could be penalized
for undershooting it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So, yeah.
Any other comments or questions?
All right.